before we kick off this podcast we are
doing something very special in
celebration of the 13-year Corridor
Channel anniversary we have a limited
edition media offline shirt in
celebration of all the Blood Sweat and
Tears that have gone into the videos
over the years we're very excited about
this but for the 13 year we wanted to do
something extra special for one lucky
person because 13 is the lucky number
after all that's why with Puget we are
going to be giving away one ten thousand
dollar Puget workstation just like the
ones we have here in the studio all you
have to do is buy one of these media
offline shirts we sell them in long
sleeve or short sleeve they're
incredibly comfortable they're a great
fit and you will be entered into a
chance to win that ten thousand dollar
PC workstation built by Puget in their
factories and shipped directly to your
door just like the ones we use here so
it's a huge opportunity for one lucky
person and of course we have a great
shirt to celebrate all the years so if
you want to snag one of these for
yourself head on over to corridor
Digital Dot store and uh good luck to
everybody thanks for watching and let's
jump into the podcast
three
and you don't have a guitar
unfortunately uh no I'm sorry but uh
doesn't quite have the same vibe to it
that's okay that's good
oh like what are you what are you
feeling today I don't know maybe we just
jump right into it
am I like I don't know this one side
whistle all right sorry I'm burning your
ears up welcome back to the corner
digital podcast episode
1734 whoa it's one of those probably oh
man yeah I'm in town this week and uh we
we're just going over some trick shots
for the next trick shot video
um but in addition to that there's a lot
going on around here we got episode of
punch for punch in the can yeah uh
Nico's off on some
panel thing right now talking to
Industry experts oh yeah it's an AI like
seminar what is it leading experts in
the AI experts yeah um so he's doing
that and uh famous people Sam and I Sam
says I have a tip on my shoulder yeah
you believe it or not well that's the
premise of this whole uh trick shot
video now which I am now in
wait I thought this was between Jake and
Jordan Allen right isn't that great I
thought it was Humanity versus the Wally
future yeah we're taking a break from
that and I get to take my hand at uh
beating Jake yeah no it's really a side
quest a chip on the shoulder yeah yeah
it's the lessons yeah and we will find
out if you learn from these lessons or
if they're like if I'm gonna teach you a
lesson or if you know I'm gonna like
teach you a lesson right exactly it'll
be one of those too yeah here's what
happened you know Jordan beat me okay
great now not I mean not great let's no
typically yeah
you be Jordan I be Jordan that was great
that was wonderful and then of course
you know uh the devil makes his return
you guys are kind of back where you
started off yeah and now you know I've
been dejected and I need to seek
additional wisdom
um so well Jordan's out uh on his
honeymoon cowardly moved to run away
right after his win right she's like
gallivanting across the world let me
just make a honeymoon here so I can go
right made up we don't even know if his
wife is real or not we think she may be
similarly yeah I know her I still I'm
not entirely sure maybe a fembot that's
possible very possible yeah I'm not
entirely convinced yet so we were at the
wedding the wedding could have been a
farce well the whole thing is probably
made it yeah yeah well he does do acting
I mean sometimes you really can you
really trust a man who started actors as
a child exactly a child actor you could
never trust a child's greatest spy yeah
look at Lindsay Lohan is he right
world's greatest spine
the world's greatest spy
yeah so yeah it could be you don't know
conspiracy theory well you know yeah I
feel bad for Jordan because you're going
to get all this practice this week and
he's going to come back all like Rusty
Dusty and you'll have your skills
sharpened yeah so I'm going to Sam uh
the sage uh to to go on a side quest if
you will to learn about
well I don't know I'm gonna learn
something oh we'll have I'll have
riddles oh prepared for you
you got to okay you know we were ripping
on some riddles over there yeah uh you
know things questions that make you
think as you're doing the trick shot
like what's the meaning of this trick
shot like what am I taking away from
this other than succeeding in the trick
shot like mentally right where am I
going dude you should have him do a
mental trick shot dude
which is just a riddle essentially
meant one mental a riddle is a mental
trick show but if it's a competition
then I have to do it too right someone
else has to deliberately
yeah yeah we'll have Nico come in with a
riddle as we're walking from one trick
shot to the next there's just a brief
riddle break
where we do mental trick shots
so yeah we I don't know if we want to
stray too far from the path here but the
idea is like you know how can I how can
I get back to my roots here so that I
can improve the skills and next time
when we go up to the this is kind of a
mini game Edition so we're going to be
doing a series of smaller more what do
you say
refined and efficient trade shots yeah
rudimentary trick shots that you
experience in life yes you know these
are the trick shots that you grow up
with right yes the trick shots you
impress your friends with in fourth
grade right real life trick shots yeah
and I think by doing that
I'll gain an appreciation for the basics
and uh and that'll really help me take
on Jordan um when he comes back and then
we're talking about dunk tanks in the
next yes dunk tanks are on the table I
think a dunk tank still is great or at
least permanently destroying his
computer yeah yeah I'm when I heard dunk
tank I am so happy that that finally is
maybe getting realized because we've
been bouncing that around for a while
just like how do we use dunk tanks oh
yeah and we can't find a good but like
Sam's brought up destroying Jordan's
computer and it's like you just have him
work on the dunk tank well how do we how
do I save Humanity
you know yeah we need to destroy the
machine the machine yeah yeah yeah get
that Guillotine blade yeah up there
final trick shot sets off the guillotine
blade
crashes down into the pieces
we'll just put on a rope and suspend it
with rope and you know just tell no one
to go underneath it except for Jordan
no it'll be funny to see that thing
crash through that piece yeah oh yeah
like destroying computer jokes are
really funny yeah we've never done it
we've only done like one yeah I think it
was one we first started working with
Puget maybe oh no we
remember that one wait is this the
bridge one oh wait there's the bridge
because see Mike pulled a little Bridge
prank oh yeah I know you're right that
was that that was the early days yeah
those early days with like Nico's first
computer body or whatever just yeah
checked it off a bridge it's so funny
because I mean I mean granted the case
and some of the cables are still useful
but it's really funny when it's like you
know it's basically just a case we're
throwing off and I was like
why did you do that
YouTubers I would have bought this
and it's like we actually emptied it out
but this time we wouldn't that's the
important distinction is that I think
it's important to have a functioning PC
that is actually working on yeah be
either like doused with a bucket of
water yeah or a guillotine blade going
straight to it get one of those streamer
like gamer PCS so you can see the
insides yeah the one that perfectly
shatters so if you had if you had
someone
go into a dunk tank and they also had a
laptop with them what's the electricity
situation there what's the the hazard to
health situation if you'll be fine
you're just short out yes yes okay it's
gonna short out it might explode a
little bit but it'll be in the end like
a desktop PC with a huge power supply in
it yeah right you might get shocked a
little bit I mean I think we all but you
know what he's he's dropping a little
zap never heard anything because it's a
shocking moment yeah warning shocking
yeah
desktop gaming PC into a dunk tank
warning shocking
man yeah so that's good I think this is
gonna be a fun one man it's
there's a lot of build up for this final
challenge between you and Jordan This is
just gonna this is what I want to do my
training yeah yeah I know they'd say
they some say that she ain't even gonna
need to do no training
he he is gonna need to do some training
he's gonna need to do some training I
need to do some training yeah yeah and
do some training
yeah so that's that's that that's that
that's happening this week
and also Matt is deep into the bowels
the bowels I'm punching up
that's Netflix approved by the way yeah
yeah Netflix like The Punch episode six
but it's cool it's cool it's cool though
I mean because it's based on that second
extraction extraction yeah which is
really sweet yeah yeah we got to see
that preview I don't think we can say
anything about it we're not gonna say
anything about it but what I will say
sweet is there's a there are some action
scenes in that movie that are like
insane yeah like jaw-dropping like world
class yeah yeah is it calling the
theaters
um didn't right or it might just be
their streaming maybe that's crazy was
it Amazon it feels like a theater thing
it feels like something that should be
understood yeah yeah who knows anyway
yeah it's really cool because we got to
recreate uh like a a prison riot scene
and it was like just freaking nuts like
just super crazy and like yeah the thing
one of the cool things like I'll no I
won't say a whole lot but the the one
crazy thing while we were filming that
was that like all there was like all
this background they needed to be
involved in it
um and oh my God yes the the background
chaos was so chaotic I think gee got
some like real stunt guys in the back
there that were really just guys that to
just make visual noise in the background
to just make it seem more chaotic
um but like the the guys were going so
there was a moment where one of the guys
was spinning another guy like holding
him up and spinning him around like a
helicopter just the way back of frame
like you could barely see it but it was
just helicoptering this guy and throwing
him around and they were just so loud
like we had to I think Christian was
like a ding that and he had to like
scream over them just to yell cut and
action it was just like yeah I was it
was real real intense I cannot wait a
lot of fun yeah that was that was a real
wild ride shooting that they spent about
70 of the Day filming his sides and then
about 30 of the Day filming geese so gee
was left with 70 of the day to just
choreograph a fight scene in the
background yeah and uh that's that's
pretty much what happened which is kind
of similar to what they did on the uh on
the Avengers set oh sure the airport
okay yeah if you've seen that stuntman
react yeah they basically just made up
their own yeah thing back there yeah
which is pretty cool and hey we got to
film with uh the director Sam Hargreaves
yeah yep um let's talk with him for a
little yeah what was that like
um he's a great guy uh very professional
gave us a lot of great insights
um yeah I and I think I believe we were
on his property right that was her yeah
we went out to Malibu it's a nice little
spot yeah it's like a little ranch like
a little ranch I feel like you're not
even right on the coast of California
it's pretty nice yeah and see the appeal
of that place it's very cool yeah shake
you got a little ranch too don't you I
do yeah recently a couple of animals I'm
about to drop my first uh Vlog at the
new place oh yeah yeah
um and uh yeah we we moved there about
two months ago
and um yeah it's more land and we got
some animals now
um so it's just a good it's a fun little
hobby slash you know Ranch and we'll see
where it goes hobby yeah I've never
heard someone describe their home well
it's like a hobby farming yeah I don't
know a little taste of all the the
quadrants of farm life well see the
thing about current farming is like so
much of it is and I've I've I've been
studying like it for a while yeah
um it's so much of it is industrialized
now that uh it's really hard for you to
make a living off of it on a small farm
most see the way that they do most of it
they do what's called confinement
farming
and that's like they'll put you know
200 head of dairy cow into like a giant
building and then uh they'll just milk
them you know whatever twice a day or
whatever and then like
it you don't even own the
cattle
um meaning like as the farmer you're
just storing them you build you build
the building and you take on all the
risk of uh building the building and and
all that stuff and the infrastructure
and then like the vertically integrated
companies the AG companies big AG will
be like okay we're gonna contract with
you for by the squirt or like yeah yeah
okay they'll contract with you for to be
able to put their animals in there but
and so it's it's just there's a lot of
risk in it and it's like very very
vertically integrated so like when 2020
happened I said uh maybe I want to get
away from this a little bit you know the
grocery stores were empty and and it was
just you know it's very uncertain times
and you know I just said what wouldn't
it be better if I could raise my own
meat and yeah of course if other people
like it you know then we'll see where it
goes but I don't think I have quite
enough land to be able to actually make
a live off of it unless we did chickens
oh okay yeah you can make living off
chickens do you have a pond I do I have
a small stock pond that you can put like
fish in there well it doesn't stay
um
it doesn't stay like full all year okay
uh it fills up when it rains and then
you know it'll then the fish drink the
water and then the fish drink the water
and that's all done
I don't know how it works that Pawn's
great though because guess what you
might not have thought of this if you
truly want to be off the grid yeah
during the next pandemic yeah you've got
to grow Reeds to make your own toilet
paper
I mean we got food you know whatever
food but like toilet paper that was the
score today right there right you press
it just like the Ancients you know yeah
why did everyone buy toilet paper
out of all the responses to something
like that why did toilet paper because
it's just like pants
it was out of necessity yeah all the
people who saw walking with that were
had terrible like analysis
I got of all the things right now you
know how easy like you ran out of toilet
paper that's like the least of your
concerns you can you know what they do
used to do before throw away divers like
they used to be yeah there used to be
cloth diapers it's like if you're out of
the toilet paper that wouldn't even be
that big of a deal yeah you could just
use a rag and then you throw it in a
bucket with some bleach and water you
get one of those you know of the day
Infinity towels that you know they used
to have in some restrooms yes
so there's paper towel dispensers but
then there's also ones that were this
giant spool of actual cloth towels oh
that loop back in so you pull it down
for a dry section dry your hands I'm
gonna clean it when it went there and
then they just take the whole thing and
put it in the laundry and re-spool it
right it's just for your easily
[Laughter]
easily modified yeah you can modify them
and and then a lot of people get away
with no toilet paper in the world
reading this thread man right apparently
like like most of the world like
obviously uses bidets or water like you
know a bucket of water and you're
literally pouring the water this is like
in poorer countries but dude the left
hand man they use their left that's
that's right yeah wow that's one word
for it yeah interesting is a word for it
um wow but you know the right hand
apparently there's like an Italian
person who's like yeah like my whole
life I grew up like you know use the
bidet but then we have like a designated
like towel for drying that's just okay
there like it's like a washcloth now I
guess I guess if it's clean it makes
sense it's just like
yeah it's like yeah we're like uh you
know but most most people you you take
that you use it a day you you throw it
throw it in the wash
what do you that's the difference in
soap and water I guess right
so yeah well it reads I mean you know
you could grow those I don't think I'm
going to get into the Reed cropping
business all right when I start my farm
okay all right I'm Gonna Be You should
continue someone should do like Sriracha
farming because that [__] is awesome
so dude
oh they don't no okay well maybe the
peppers did I miss there's no Sriracha
you can't buy Sriracha anywhere oh did
the factory get closed out yeah it got
like [__] I don't know what I think I
know those are exactly the hamster
having where like they were you know
business was booming and so they were
making so much sauce that everyone like
you know a mile radius or whatever was
like like being pepper
yeah so I know they're dealing with that
so maybe that yeah there's like a
shortage of it right I mean I gotta look
it up because this is important
stopped having Sriracha yeah there's a
sriracha and I and I know this because
I'm a Sriracha guy I do like sriracha
and I just have realized that like it's
missing from the shelves it's just like
completely yeah yeah it's like you know
oh interesting there's uh last Summer's
drought in Mexico that's what it was
because they're experiencing a shortage
of the actual ingredients right
from Mexico it was Chili Pepper farming
is it was processed in here I might be
able to do I don't know if I'm far
enough South to do Chili Peppers okay
the bush country of the Hill Country is
really that's really sad that's really
sad you know it makes me really want to
have Sriracha right now exactly all the
off-brand Sriracha sucks it does it's
there's a problem they put like too much
vinegar or too much sugar in there or
like they're never spicy that's for sure
damn right Sriracha brand Sriracha is
the most perfectly balanced sauce it's
like come on it's garlic and peppers
yeah how do you [__] it up yeah exactly
I have a bottle of sriracha in my fridge
yeah hold on to that it's like Precious
it has the crust it's like probably the
year long crust is on the thing yeah it
doesn't go bad though yeah it sort of
has like a half-life maybe but it's like
call me later we'll talk yeah yeah
please yeah we'll make a deal in fact
I'm just gonna say Sriracha everything
sucks except for the sauce Sriracha
chips that's true I agree with that yeah
stuff that has it is never the actual
sauce flavor just want the sauce what is
this it's just they're just taking the
name they're just licensing the name
yeah and doing something similar that's
right yeah it's a farce maybe we should
start a hot sauce company yeah hell yeah
yeah yeah
what would we call that
um
hot takes hot takes hot hot takes
[Laughter]
okay well yeah well that's about as far
as I went leave a comment down below
let's let's let yeah let's let the
audience do the work here let's know
what our hot sauce should be called okay
and then we will start it yeah Nick and
I also have been talking about a series
of videos we could shoot on my property
yeah well the first of which maybe not
on your property but possibly near it is
VFX artists try farming for a day yes
okay yeah this is an idea yeah we I
don't think we have to leave California
for that but if we if if it was a part
of a series of videos that we did we
could easily do it there too but the
idea is just exactly that we were we
weren't going to say VFX artists we were
going to say like we we made our entire
tech company farm for a day
yeah and it's just we go out just
getting sweaty stuff Bros
the Weeping Tech bro weeping
Metropolitan 30 year olds
yeah dude no I mean honestly I would
love to try farming for a day
there's a there's a there's I find that
there's a certain like I don't know just
like peace in it
um it would be terrifying to have to do
it for your living I think because
you're so dependent on
what the Earth does what the animals do
what your crops do like all of that
stuff but to do it as a hobby I find it
really peaceful
um because you get to like spend time
you know outside you get to like get to
know the animals there's like a
relationship that you build with them
um and all that stuff and then of course
like it makes the process of when you
are eating
uh like it make you you know there's it
has more gravitas I think because you've
so an heirloom is anything that has has
been you know uh like transferred uh uh
the same plant has been living for many
many years so the we have these heirloom
garlic plants that the previous owners
put in and those garlic that garlic
comes from her original Ranch that she
grew up on uh so this this strain of
garlic is like
a hundred years old nice
um and it's just been yeah that's gotta
be some good garlic we haven't tried it
yet it hasn't you know it hasn't gotten
to full growth yet it comes from a good
pedigree yeah good garlic um but then
like you know so we got two cows the
other day well what yeah casually so
I've been studying Dexter cows okay for
a little while is this spot
they murdered I want to hear about it so
no so they're not Dexter
no Dexter Dexter's are an Irish breed
that were raised on Ireland and the
island of Ireland and uh so they're
smaller than a lot of other breeds
they're not minis they're just like not
as big as some of the big Angus cows and
stuff
um but they don't eat as much so they're
really food efficient because they're
they were
um evolved on an island so there wasn't
a ton of food sources and so they're
really efficient eaters they have
themselves uh they're really pretty
friendly and they're easier to handle
because of their size so like we got
this so we have a a bull and we have a
cow
um so Ebola is an unfixed uh you know
male and then there's a steer which is a
fixed male and then there's a uh there's
a heifer which is a female that hasn't
had a calf yet and then there's a cow
which is a female that's proven to have
a calf and so we have a calf and a bowl
and the bull the the cow is like pretty
scared of me still like she's she'll sit
behind the bowl and she's not quite sure
because she was raised on like 600 acres
um for the first three years of her life
she's still kind of figuring it out
um but then the bowl I got him to eat
out of my hand the other day that was a
big that was a big uh bonding moment
threshold yeah Milestone or Watershed or
whatever you want to call it
um because for the first like two weeks
he was you know he'd come up to me but
he wouldn't get too close and then the
other day yeah I got him to eat out of
my hand so I'm just building that bond
with him and you know he's figuring out
okay I can trust this guy he's got good
stuff for me whenever he comes around
I've got a call for them so when I go
out there and I call them and they come
running over um
uh it's a it's a it's a
a little whistle yeah
oh yeah and then I say come on cows and
Austin Powers theme you know what up
cows and then I have another one for the
ponies which is a
oh they can distinguish this yeah
they're kind of they're learning to the
dog is just like what is usually did you
call so what's your what's your plans
with the cows what is it milk is it uh
More Cows so milking is kind of a like a
subsection of cattle raising which is
you know like any mammal they only
produce milk when they're you know
producing for a calf
um so if you're gonna do like Dairy you
need there's certain breeds and then of
course you need to make sure that the
dog has a calf so it's always producing
um for that calf um but you could melt
them yeah but you'd want to you what
you'd wanna do is have the calf and then
bottle feed the calf and then hope that
it's a it's a heifer and then uh you can
you can get it friendly and then once it
comes to age then you can you know milk
it
um but yeah you could do some really
good food with that I like hadn't put
that together that they have to have a
calf I mean it's obvious now that I
think about it but I just assumed just
like chickens where they'll always be
like laying flanks you know well there
are there are like there are breeds that
produce more okay you know than other
breeds
um damn so like people would always have
to make sure that I mean when people
like had a milk cow like for sustenance
they'd always have to get it uh I guess
yeah I mean the thing is the thing is
you're if you are raised I mean if
you're raising them for for sale or for
your own consumption like you do always
want to have
the cows breeding because like that's
where the actual value in the animal is
so you know basically once you they're
they're they're is it called gestation
when they grow out of when you grow a
baby is that called yeah yeah the
gestation periods are nine months long
just like a person so you can kind of
time them but um basically yeah like
once like once a
once any animal cattle animal gets to
two years old then pretty much they're
ready to either breed or you're they're
ready to butcher
um so you can
you can choose what you want to do
obviously but like you would you have
them on those regular Cycles so like
every year they're calving yeah and
every and and if you leave if you don't
wean the cat the calf off of the mom
then you know she's gonna produce milk
for for probably until right up before
the next one is born a year later but
most of the time people if you're beef
if you're beef farming you'll wean them
so that they're not doing that
um but if you don't wean them then of
course they'll still produce yeah it's
crazy like I never
thought that I would get cows or pigs oh
you got pigs too yeah yeah that's right
cows and the pigs
Chip and Dale there's a Chip and Dale
yeah one's a one's a boar
uh and one's a borrow so a borrow is a
fixed male okay but a boar is a unfixed
male and so one of them is like uh
many something or another I don't know
and the other one's a Kuni Kuni
um which is a pretty popular uh like
homesteading breed okay they've become
more popular now I I wasn't actually
didn't want to get Kuni Kunis because
they take 18 months to grow out whereas
like a Durock which is another breed
that also produces a red meat
those grow out in like
10 months eight months so
um so this is for the bacon then this is
something
this is all about the bacon well the
cows are too a little bit okay yeah the
cows are definitely yeah you don't want
to say the thing is with the bull and
with the cow that I currently have
that's like the start of a herd
see those ones actually those ones are
probably going to breed for a long time
if they if they do well and then but
then they're calves you know you want to
grow it out and then of course like then
you have the situation where you need to
separate the bull from the heifers if
they're his kids because you don't want
that to happen don't want that to happen
yeah
um so then you have to like start
panicking them and you need to bring in
another Bowl it gets more complicated
yeah if you're doing it that way right
yeah okay interesting yeah then we have
20 chickens oh my God you have 20
chickens Jesus Christ you really do have
a full Farm happening so that's like you
like sell the eggs oh yeah you can I
think well the there's nine of them
there's ten of them that are baby chicks
still and so they're only three months
old doing about another three months
they'll start laying eggs and then we'll
have way more eggs than we can consume
so then yeah you you can start selling
them and technically you know if you're
like industrially selling them you need
to have it there's FDA like
yeah regulations on all that stuff but
if you're just selling them to friends
and stuff then yeah it's nice though the
eggs are really good they're in all
these different colors and
um they lay everything almost every day
like fresh eggs or something else man
there's
you don't realize like how bad the eggs
we are until you have a fresh freaking
egg like straight from the chicken
that's why we got into it because we our
friend when we were when Wendy and I
were living in Minnesota like a couple
years ago uh we we got fresh eggs and we
were like what are these like one of our
friends we brought some eggs for them
and she's like guys the eggs I got uh or
her friend brought her eggs the yolks
look weird no she said the eggs one of
these eggs is blue do you think that's
okay to eat
like yeah
what is it what's the difference in like
the taste it's just like it's like for
me I noticed the yolk was way different
it like was like creamier it felt creamy
yeah I mean it's richer um yeah like I
mean after they're cooked I don't think
you notice the biggest difference but
you can tell right away once you crack
it right like it's like is it is it like
watery is it like thick or is it like
holding its form better like you know
sometimes you take an egg and you crack
it on the pan to fry and it just goes
like
and it kind of like it looks like you
just poured like water right and it like
it starts to Splinter off and you know
like little little Trails yeah yeah
you put it down it stays stays together
it stays like a circle oh yeah okay yeah
I don't know you learn when we go to
Texas yeah we're gonna be
[Laughter]
all of Jake's again through the website
Jake do you worry about like having a
bond like too much of a bond with any of
these animals and then like well damn
now I gotta I mean he's gonna be my
dinner I thought but you know I kind of
think about it like in this I realize
this isn't for everybody I realize that
you know like there's a
there's often a misconstruction that
happens with like raising animals or
hunting or whatever but to me it's like
okay this is this is this animal's
purpose you know it's it's not just
meant to roam errantly and it's like
been bred for this over the course of
Millennials yeah yeah to do this exact
thing and so you're just facilitating
that process trying to make it as
peaceful and as enjoyable for the animal
while it's alive and then of course when
you go to butcher it making sure that
you're doing it as humanely and as
efficiently as possible
um and that's really that's really all
it is and it's like it's a it's a give
and take you know they give you
sustenance they give you life and in
exchange you do the same thing for them
that's actually really good for the
planet too yeah it is actually it's
better than like a lot of you folks
around here you know you don't have a
choice well yeah I know and it's not
like it's not like I think everybody
should do this like I realize there's
like everyone's got a particular role to
play and and of course in a major city
you you just can't do something like
that because it's completely ridiculous
to even you know think about the
logistics that would go into that and
also
when you both things like both big
cities and small farms and things they
both have a role to play that are
uh harmonious with one another like the
the City offers
development
technology progress ideas
the the rural offers food it offers like
retreat it offers you know like it
offers both of those things have a role
to play so yeah I do worry about getting
too attached to them sometimes but at
the same time I just think well this is
this is its purpose and so this is and
this is my purpose yeah
heck yeah it's really cool man yeah I
can only hope to have at least some
chicken someday man that's yeah yeah
chickens are really easy I want to have
that I would recommend if you have you
don't need you you only need like I know
dude a small space I have some grass on
my eight by twelve balcony I get like
three on in my studio
[Laughter]
when they lay an egg they have to
basically you know when when a human has
a baby yeah like everybody you know when
a mom has a baby yeah
congratulations yeah you gotta you gotta
let everybody know like you have a baby
shower chickens do the exact same thing
every morning every morning yeah they go
out they lay an egg and then they get up
on like a high they get up on a roost
and then they go
and if you have a rooster the rooster
will call back to them so there'll just
be this eruption of chaotic noise yeah
every time an egg is laid sure so you
have that going on right that's really
crazy
yeah that's good okay something to
consider but I think I can make it work
you know yeah maybe you can put it
inside
I can put it inside yeah there'll be
indoor roosters indoor chickens yeah
yeah okay yeah I'll think about that
yeah Wendy's Grandma used to have a hand
that wouldn't lay and she said okay
we're gonna turn you into stew and then
she like had a conversation with the
hand and then the hen oh this just came
in one day after they had that
conversation and it jumped up on her
kitchen table and in Mexico they have
these little woven baskets that you keep
tortillas in not to keep them warm and
it laid and it laid an egg right in that
basket and every and then every day it
would come in and lay an egg in that
basket oh wow yeah wow wow yeah it's
pretty fast that is a funny story yeah
that's a good one
and that's the other thing once they
grow out they have a egg laying sort of
like ideal egg-laying phase of their
life but then you get what's called a
dual purpose chicken which means you can
eat it or later and so once it ages out
of that period around like three years
then you can you know you can stew hem
them and of course if you allow them to
brood before they get to that age then
they replenish their the flock okay
um so it's all about like looking at it
as a totality of the species Health
replenishing yeah than it is any
individual animal okay
yeah you don't want to be going back to
the livestock store every time yeah buy
more no damn I've made a very perfect
cylinder out of it I've been really
working really refined that throughout
the podcast it looks like a crayon it
does that's Play-Doh that's crazy it is
very I'm very impressed behold I mean
just in comparison
yeah
you can throw away all the fidget
Spinners now
Play-Doh at their desk
can it stand up
yeah we're going to film a video the
first one which is uh how much mud does
it take to hide from Predator yeah yeah
dude I can't wait for this one probably
the most intense Jake movie myth yeah
dude yeah it will involve a real hunt
yeah
an airsoft gun with the thermal scope on
it and then like the final test is we
have three mud piles
have one BB in your airsoft gun
you shoot one of them you get to shoot
one pile with your bb gun and hopefully
yeah so the question is how much mud
does it take to hide from a thermal
optic you know can you
it seems like it would take a lot based
on the little videos I've been looking
up on YouTube like yeah
I typed in yeah
that's a very different part of the
internet let me say I can see all those
mud men all right you can see yeah
really yes yeah but it looks like what
the most they do is they just rub it on
their skin to be lazy like muddy yeah we
can do better I'm thinking chicken wire
Exo Suit yeah and you use that as a kind
of a packing you know she can wear it
yes yes so you can really pack it up
yeah yeah you kind of have to just take
it on we're talking about kick it we're
talking like mobile game mouth and the
nose
[Laughter]
lines and all yeah there will be some of
those mobile game ads man oh yeah dude
they're doing something new and I almost
want to make it since we I want to make
a sequel almost because it's like I'm
thinking about I definitely have been
collecting more but they're doing
something now where they're making these
apology videos like they're apologizing
for lying about their game that it's not
real a real real game but and so other
and then they're giving them points like
they're giving people points to go play
the real real game uh but the apology
videos are just as insane as the regular
mobile game the one I keep seeing is the
please don't skip please don't skip
please
they're live action he's just trying to
like get me to find one of those because
I was referencing it and oh I've got it
I couldn't find those well I have it
yeah why did he ask you I have I've been
collecting these for years go ask Matt
you know Jesus
like please there's a team of developers
really hard on this game please don't
skip yeah we made this game For Your
Entertainment pleasure yeah
it's a collection of like actors in
business suits that are just like on
their hands and knees begging you to
like I'm sorry we're sorry download our
game what are they doing this yeah
I don't know why praying hands like oh
with these mobile games forgive us yeah
I think it's just that like they they
figure out what works the first like
five seconds like what gets people to
click on it and then they just are all
they all decide to do that you know they
all they're following all these Trends
man uh
it's so great I like how there's a
resident expert on almost everything in
Corridor that's the mobile game guy I
guess it's fast Farm guy yeah it's like
the true worldwide study on attention
seeking and it like yeah to capture
attention in the shortest time pause
yeah they're I mean they're Pioneers
honestly I mean that brings us to
another video we shot last week which is
the child psychologist yeah action video
yeah that was really interesting to
shoot for me yeah it was I'm not one
parent to give us a glimpse yeah I mean
I don't know anything about that let's
just say I was but yeah Sam could give
you a better one I mean yeah I mean in a
nutshell uh you know obviously we got
kids and so it's it's a thing it exists
uh but very specifically we're going to
children's content that's on YouTube and
kind of of the breadth of
all of it everything from you know the
classic Spider-Man Elsa stuff to Coco
melon uh and then you have in the middle
like the Ryan's World stuff where it's
like are these children actors like do
they fall underneath like child labor
laws in the film industry kind of
covering kind of a little bit of
everything on just like you know a is
this you know good content for children
or like ultimately like what are these
messages that we're getting from this
stuff
um to
yeah I know all the weird dark stuff
yeah for sure so yeah I mean I I walked
away with it with a pretty positive
outlook to be totally honest yeah
because ultimately it comes down to the
the real old-fashioned like don't watch
too much TV you know that's that's
really that's ultimately the message
with the majority of stuff sure um even
you know so yeah because even like the
quote War stuff that we pulled up she
was going like well look if we break it
down like this you know there's actually
positive things positive takeaways that
you can kind of look at here there are
some you know negative ones as well but
yeah you know
you know as parents you're just like
stop watching your iPad you know it's
like stop watching crap yeah it's like
that's never gonna end I'm curious did
you like did you walk away with anything
that you would apply as a parent from
that like or was it kind of just like
reinforcing like okay yeah I'm this is
kind of like the right path yeah yeah I
mean I already do that yeah yeah each
time they pick it up I set a timer on
there and then it goes off and then I
put it down that's it yeah yeah like I
watched something I mean I I see the
stuff they watch and I'm for sure either
like I'm like okay that's all right or I
go I ban the channel yeah okay move on
yeah that's good and then the trick that
I do lately is uh
when they're not using it I go on there
and search for a bunch of cool stuff so
that way it like automatically will
recommend them stuff that they're
interested in oh okay yeah so playing
the algorithm yeah my older yeah because
Gideon is
uh he he's just starting to like write
right now and like do the Reading
Writing thing and um so yeah he can't
like necessarily search for stuff on his
own yeah so yeah then so that works yeah
okay cool yeah yeah there's a lot of
techniques you can apply although it's
really funny so sometimes I use the Siri
feature on the iPad to like set the
timer I'm like hey Siri
set a timer for 15 minutes and so Gideon
my older kid doesn't he doesn't use that
feature but sometimes I say set a timer
for 15 minutes and then he quickly yells
like no 30 minutes
my younger daughter who's three whenever
she's like kind of like angry with him
goes over there and she's starting to
say like Hey Siri timer five minutes
she's like trying to get the voice I
don't think it really recognizes kid
voices it never works with their yeah
with them saying it has to be an adult
or someone who's like actually yeah
because it does like voice ID stuff too
yeah okay she's like I'm gonna put a
timer on yeah
oh man that's so funny yeah that's
probably it too like the slight
incoherence of it yeah it's like my just
that yeah I mean obviously you know if
you're listening to this don't let this
stop you from watching the video because
it is a really interesting breakdown and
also the Our Guest was like a look very
legit legit yeah it's very published
she's like uh like an author and uh
practicing and you know everything yeah
um yeah but yeah just big takeaway just
make sure you know what your kids are
watching and don't let them watch crap
forever they take away parent yeah yeah
like quality time like be present yeah
even if like for me like the cool thing
was hearing her say like hey even this
bad stuff we're watching can be good if
you're there parenting your kid and
talking to them and asking them
questions about like what they're
watching think about it that's really
interesting yeah I've noticed that too
though my kids will ask me questions if
they're what if they're watching
something that's kind of on the edge of
you know what I would allow them to
watch they'll ask me questions about it
and then I can sit there and explain to
them what it is there
um so is that yeah that's helpful
amen
quality time yeah that's what we learned
yeah quality it's all QT QT you get some
QT on that farm yep yeah yeah QT QT on
the farm we kind of went full fully
around but let's go back to the farm
let's get some other videos
yeah we have like a whole list of our
ideas
yeah we just got to like we got to like
choose
I really want to do the battleship one
yeah so we we build a boat yeah it's
well there's two build a boats okay
there's one build a boat which is for
the battleship and then there's one
build a boat for uh Marine assault yeah
just Naval Warfare so we get up we get a
small pond and then we put up you know
like a two by like a four by eight panel
run across it in the middle of it and
then you have your ships on one side and
the other person has their ships on the
other and then you have flaming arrows
and you shoot flaming arrow over the
over the wall and you play Battleship
and if you burn down all their ships
then you win then you win yeah all right
that's like a viking funeral Battleship
yeah well and then there's Viking
funeral challenge which is you know your
great grandfather's ashes are floating
off the sea and you're the young Warrior
who can't become a warrior until you hit
the boat this is your moment yeah this
is your moment your whole family's
watching it's like my favorite scene
endorsement yes yeah
just trying to shoot the flaming arrow
and it keeps like flopping out of the
boat in front of the hole he's like the
like chieftain in front of the whole
village oh [__] I can't perform right
now I finally saw Northman oh yeah North
movie yeah yeah do you think what'd you
think about it what did you think about
it did you just got to my reaction
Christian
I don't want to do it again I like it a
lot I've ranted a lot on a podcast I
hate it wait wait okay you hate it okay
wow I [__] like it when she came out
you said you loved it
they all convinced ourselves this would
be Sam's like Soul movie that he'd bond
with yeah that's you think I'm a basic
[__]
[Laughter]
yeah
sorry that's a viking thing right yeah
I don't know I'm just thinking about
some Looney Tunes I don't even know if
it's speaking of Looney Tune [__] what
about the north yeah right well listen I
I thought they did a good job staying in
the world
except for the fire moment dude
was fine that was sick though magma yeah
it was a little bit the Dork the Dark
Soul scene is is cool I think that's
where there's the skeleton guy and
there's a fight and that's not sweet
yeah yeah I just don't like that when
you just think about it it's like he
walked in the boat and picked up the
sword and walked out oh yeah oh here's
what happened he just walked in there
got the sword exactly
oh there it is
like you do you do a whole movie where
it's like that it's just a guy he's like
oh glad that one didn't happen
glad that was easy
yeah this could have gone way worse I
thought that movie was pretty cool
there's no such thing as giant skeleton
Knights
thank God there were no skeletons in
there that could have been bad yeah okay
not gonna come to life all right
[Laughter]
do you dream of
Finland Saga yeah okay
yeah you watched it too right yeah yeah
it's great
um
like obviously it's animated so all the
sword fights can be really cool yeah uh
but then also just like from a storyline
perspective it doesn't I don't know it
just it stays really true to like that
time period and then like the like the
weird brutality of of the era and Anna
it's really cool yeah and I'm totally
gonna read the Manga after the season
ends because I'm not gonna wait three
years for this third season that's how
long it's gonna take well the first
season uh came out a long time ago yeah
so I didn't realize like Netflix just
picked it up probably I don't know I
don't know it just took him a long time
you know like Attack on Titan yeah oh
yeah it's very similar it does take
forever it's a great Viking anime if you
haven't watched it I know I never
thought it well after watching it that's
when I was like hey you know we were
working on rock paper scissors like yeah
what if we did anime
Civil War yes like it's like
authenticating yes anime American Civil
War that would be great where it's like
really intense and not like a joke
right yeah right like it sounds like a
joke you explain Finland Saga it's like
it's an anime Viking show and everyone's
like huh okay anime and you're like dude
it's serious
you're not having fun no anime to the
Civil War
yeah totally we just need a good writer
man yeah let's take it super seriously
good writers are hard to find
yeah yeah especially ones you're like
historical [__] as well yeah yeah true
yeah man
but that would be cool oh super cool
yeah
is that all we're gonna film out there
then we're gonna do the Viking stuff uh
we're gonna do uh you're forgetting one
real important one which is real life
organ Trail simulator oh yeah oh yeah
Sam we need you in on this all right
that's one we've been talking about for
a while what the video is I'm not really
sure
so I'm sure we can whip some up
um no dude I think that would be fun to
go out to Texas and shoot a bunch of
videos yeah okay I gotta do that
any any other bright Texas ideas like um
like fish out of water stories yeah
who can Jordan Coleman's from there so
you can't really do that story yeah
that's true she's from Florida oh okay
her family lives there right right yeah
my family lives there too actually a lot
of you have the same situation yeah it's
a very similar you're like from Florida
but also kind of yeah yeah yeah visiting
Texas a lot yeah they're all moving
around where
uh it's in Dallas okay so I'm a little
different yeah yeah Texas is very big
it's huge yeah yeah yeah it's 700 miles
800 miles across Pure Freedom
for 800 miles and the distance from uh
Brownsville which is at the tiny bottom
corner to the top uh of the Panhandle if
you flip that and go up you in you're in
Des Moines Iowa wow wow wow
geez that's why you don't mess with it
that's big
brother well
oh I feel like we all learned something
today yeah you know I learned a lot I
learned that Sam hates the north video
yeah he does yeah
like each time you say that I just
visualize my list of gripes it's very
disappointing that's too bad uh but yeah
cringy to be honest
[Laughter]
is Sam wrong there's a couple things I
gotta make known you decide what are you
making known well that's a proclamation
so you if you haven't seen uh Peter's
rest stop check it out oh that'll just
came out yeah
um made with pure magic yes made with
the finest magic uh the the childhood
the child psychologist react episode is
coming out at the end of this week
um when this video comes out
um and then uh very importantly very
importantly
there's something happening
a big uh you know what something's
happening
yes yes that's kind of a big deal guys
kind of a big deal if you want to win
a ten thousand dollar Puget PC just like
the ones we use here in the studio we're
doing a giveaway right now uh we have a
limited edition media offline shirt
that's on quarter Digital Dot store if
you buy it we're gonna pick one person
who buys it and we're gonna send and
Puget has agreed to work with us on this
they're gonna send them a computer just
like the ones we use here directly to
that person so yeah or maybe just like
the shirt in which case you know you can
get one yeah and then maybe a computer
shows up and you're just like wow wow I
use max but this is sweet
it's a pretty good deal
I mean like yeah it'll probably last you
like I don't know at least five or six
years of top tier performance you know
no big deal yeah and of course with that
you get everything that you get when you
buy a PC with them which is all the
customer service and stuff so yeah it's
a pretty cool thing from them yeah yeah
good folks [__] it so anyway if you want
that Link's in the description or just
go to quarter digital.store yeah and uh
yeah thanks for watching Everybody uh
this was a fun one I feel like you
learned a lot I feel I feel like I
learned a lot I mean Matt learned how to
make a croissant yeah
with his Play-Doh so the Play-Doh
continues here on the corner cast and uh
any last words gentlemen
what do you want on your Tombstone
maybe offline
pineapple media
yeah
some ham pineapple and ham all right see
you later everybody have a great day